heroin welcome to this video I am
harmony 50 70 does not have a name
attached so we don't know that we play
[Music]
sorry this recently got popped actually
after Queen c7 and it is surprising
interesting this line I've saw an
article then in latest new HS magazine
by your own bosch in this SOS series and
it really looked interesting I did not
really study this article i was just
browsing through it so let's see him
endings are usually quite ok for black
in the sicilian but here he has some
weaknesses on the queenside and the
half-open age file structure looks nice
for wine d5 so how do we do this special
p.m. normal moves
analog know exactly what black should do
here maybe put some pressure on the
centered my play is also not very clear
to me where I develop and so on I don't
like to see Bishop before you for some
reason hmm maybe it was a bit bit slow I
cannot easily develop my bishop now look
like would be one as he's extremely lame
hmm
I don't quite know how to play here 9725
is also something that strikes me as a
little bit uncomfortable I don't know if
each five is a move him and I'm 97 lat
so far not the end of the world but ok
I'll go for that I really don't don't
quite understand the position i think
maybe nights he and night a form comes
close to this square
after more or less yeah Bishop c5 I
don't know this is good I don't know
this leads to anything that's what I'm
trying to say complain even 91 and
threatening Bishop e2 not quite clear to
me maybe we should still do that again
so I'm covering this and tending Bishop
b2
you can go to age 6 dome can just
retreat yeah but this is maybe not that
bad maybe I'm completely not
understanding this position very poor
very much possible bit I think this is
not bad for me is this this thing I also
have before ideas before I like bishop
be to push this back be fined and take
control over the dark squares maybe and
it's taking quite a bit of time
[Music]
yeah I really have to reinvent the wheel
a I can absolutely no experience with
the position like that so I'm pushing
this back I'm not pushing this back okay
my idea is to take I was thinking before
and then like take and Bishop e3 but
maybe this is not very well supported
yeah he wants to he wants to open this
this up I can also try that actually
take and light III here and then take
his pawn but he would probably never
defend the pawn let's do this anyway I
mean if he takes this and you can start
to sacrifice yeah like this to sacrifice
material him because of his better
development there maybe give for him I
take this is rook caj and he will get it
back it's not great I move the night
though he will go D for the tech g2 okay
maybe this is just bad for me actually
now that I look at this that looks bad
yeah not good
I don't know how bad this is for me but
it looks pretty awful and we should be
for one thing no he just tries to double
why not young that I cannot allow so
nine to five I can also play nitey one
and just take it but I don't know this
is a good idea anyway okay did not even
recognize that this is possible at him
so what to do to do time money i can go
nite safai for probably it's probably
equal
can I do this side prolly no Bishop c4
even a song and I don't know what I
totally know what I'm doing here am I
playing for windy or what doesn't make
any sense to be honest we agreed we'd
check check check cannot do anything
active here in this position
unfortunately check check check grah our
third row is plain quickly awesome white
forfeits on time oh he got really
quickly I mean I was offering a drawer
just to like him to cop out but then I
forgot to play quickly actually yeah
very very difficult game I didn't
understand this position at all like
this is this position I have absolutely
no idea what's going on Jim it's not
good yeah it's just not good a castle
was probably a bad idea i mean this this
position is just bad for white and yeah
maybe I can
I don't know I didn't want to make a
draw somehow which which is weird
consider that my position is bad but um
check can't you two so i'll continue and
yeah I don't understand this position at
all you probably five isn't great
computer wants to play move like before
I am it's not something you just just
plain and this is probably not good yeah
I also didn't really have Nyjah for on
the agenda I was just thinking he goes
back to the seven hmm Joe that's a
difficult move and this is a funny idea
extremely complex pollution and they
have really no idea what's going on you
know I think you played that plate that
nicely maybe I can somehow equalize if
I'm extremely precise but I wasn't ok
guys thanks for watching